Wir werden immer mehr.
Fast acht Milliarden Menschen
leben auf der Erde.
2050 werden drei Viertel
von uns in Städten wohnen.
Weil die Städte immer größer werden,
verdrängen sie Wälder und Landschaften,
in denen Tiere leben.
Schlimmstenfalls verlieren
die Tiere so ihre Heimat.
Oder aber:
Die Tiere richten sich in
den wachsenden Städten ein –
wie in der deutschen Hauptstadt Berlin.
Hier sollen inzwischen allein bis zu
4.000 Wildschweine zu Hause sein.
Nahrung finden sie ganz leicht,
weil wir Menschen überall
Essenreste herumliegen lassen.
Mit der natürlichen Ernährung
der Tiere hat das nichts zu tun.
Die Tiere leben in Parks, auf Friedhöfen
oder stillgelegten Industriebrachen.
Dabei kommen wir und
die Tiere uns sehr nahe.
Dann können schon mal Krankheitserreger
vom Tier auf uns Menschen überspringen.
Wegen uns Menschen und unserer Art zu
leben sind viele Tiere inzwischen bedroht.
Von den bis zu neun Millionen
Tier- und Pflanzenarten weltweit
sterben jedes Jahr tausende aus.
Wachsende Städte,
Luftverschmutzung
und der von uns verursachte Klimawandel,
der dafür sorgt,
dass es immer wärmer wird, sind Gründe.
Damit wir gut mit den Tieren zusammenleben
können, müssen wir sie bei allem,
was wir tun, berücksichtigen.
Wenn wir Städte bauen, ist es wichtig,
Räume für die Tiere mitzuplanen.
In der indischen Metropole Delhi
sind zum Beispiel mehr als 100
Schmetterlingsarten zu Hause.
Viele Freiwillige haben kleine
Parks für sie hergerichtet,
so dass auch die kleinen Insekten in der
großen Stadt genug Nahrung finden.
Auch sonst schwindet immer mehr natürlicher
Lebensraum für Tiere und Pflanzen.
Wir roden Wälder, um mehr Platz
für unsere Felder zu bekommen.
Kühe brauchen Weideflächen.
Der Andenbär in Kolumbien
weiß das nur zu gut.
Da er durch die Felder der Menschen
immer weniger Platz im Wald hat,
kommt er ihnen auf der Suche
nach Futter immer näher.
Wir haben aber Angst um unsere
Ernten und bekämpfen den Bären.
Dabei ist er wichtig für den Wald.
Der Andenbär verteilt
über seinen Kot die Samen,
die später für Früchte im Wald sorgen.
Also müssen wir Menschen lernen,
mit dem Andenbär zu leben
und ihm Schutz
und Unterstützung gewähren.
Eine andere Möglichkeit:
Wir Menschen sorgen für eine Landwirtschaft,
die den Lebensraum der Tiere nicht zerstört.
Ein Beispiel:
Bauern in Belize pflanzen
ihren Kakao mitten im Wald.
Zwischen unseren Städten zerschneiden
Straßen die Heimat von Tieren:
Wildschweine, Rehe, Frösche, aber
auch kleine Käfer können sich deshalb
nur noch unter Lebensgefahr
in ihrem Zuhause bewegen.
Es gibt inzwischen so viele Straßen,
dass man die Erde viele
hundert Male umrunden könnte.
Wildbrücken für die Tiere über
die Straßen oder Amphibientunnel
sind ein möglicher Ausweg.
Auch unter Wasser sind Tiere
und Pflanzen nicht vor uns sicher.
Plastikmüll im Meer, schmutzige Abwässer
und rücksichtslose Urlauber
zerstören die Unterwasserwelt.
Besonders betroffen: Korallenriffe, wie hier vor
der Küste der Dominikanischen Republik.
90 Prozent davon sind bereits
zerstört oder schwer geschädigt.
Wissenschaftler züchten Korallen nun im
Labor und bringen sie später ins Meer.
Eine wichtige Arbeit,
denn ein Viertel der Meeresbewohner
brauchen die Korallenriffe zum Überleben.
Noch sind viele Projekte zum Schutz
der Lebensräume der Tiere klein
im Vergleich zum Raubbau an Flächen.
Studien zufolge müsste die Hälfte
der Landflächen und Ozeane
unter Schutz gestellt werden,
um weiteres Artensterben zu vermeiden.
50 Staaten haben einen
wichtigen Schritt getan.
Bis 2030 wollen sie gemeinsam
30 Prozent der Land- und Meeresflächen
auf diese Weise bewahren.